David, for all the talk about voter turnout, will
it actually happen this year? This is a great
question, because every election someone says
it's a term. It's turnout. It's a turnout election
in a mathematical sense when 45 percent of the
country doesn't vote in presidential elections.
Turnout alone can flip an election. Sure. It's not
about convincing people about one candidate over
another. It's about if nearly half the country
doesn't vote. Finding people who agree with
you in getting them to vote is a potentially
mathematically viable strategy. Does it ever
actually happen? Well, it's often underwhelming,
particularly when candidates have counted on young
voters who love me are gonna rocket me to victory.
Bernie is an example. And then it doesn't happen.
So it doesn't it doesn't always happen. However,
we have a few interesting data points. In 2018,
the midterm had a much higher turnout than the
2014 midterm and the 2010 midterm. If you see
that as an indicator for what will happen in 2020,
as far as turnout goes, it suggests big turnout in
2020. The other side of this is if you look at
how many people have already voted as of today,
it's millions and millions when it was very few.
At this point in 2016, some are saying that means
turnout is off the wall and it's probably bad
for Trump. The counter is multiple states. Most
states, half the states, I don't know the number,
but because of the pandemic, many, many states
have expanded and encouraged absentee ballots
and absentee voting. So it's not that naturally,
without anything being different, the number of
early votes have exploded by orders of magnitude.
They've exploded. But because we have a pandemic
and states have actually gone out of their way
like they've never done before, to get people
to vote absentee or or to vote early. So I don't
think that's really the sign. I think we're going
to have to wait and see. Trump has been repeating
the left has no enthusiasm. That seems very
wrong. And if you look even from the past weekend
at early voting lines, people waiting in line,
twelve hours to vote. Part of the reason they're
waiting that long is, of course. Early voting has
been hampered, particularly in Democratic areas.
We've seen reductions in polling places
and people thrown off voter rolls. So they
get there and they're not on the list. And
okay, fine. But there does not seem to be
a shortage of enthusiasm. And in the end, it is
really hard to get people who aren't interested in
politics to vote. It's tough. It really is tough.
Nearly half the country isn't interested enough to
have voted in 2016. That's a very difficult
situation. It's an opportunity if you can
activate people. But it is a very, very difficult
thing to do. That's where my head is right now.
I do think we will see record turnout partially
because the population is bigger than ever. But
I believe there is enthusiasm. Is it going to be
a blow out of the water record turnout? I think
it will be record turnout. I don't think it will
be. One guy called and said he expects. I think
he said one hundred and sixty million votes. I
don't think we're going to get 160 million votes
at all if we do. I will eat my hat. I don't
have any hats so I can make that promise. But
I do think we will see record turnout. We
have a great bonus show planned for you today.
Get instant access instant by
signing up at join Pacman Dot.